some airlines are offering discounts to
passengers stranded when Wow air
suddenly shut down some 4000 travelers
in North America and Europe scrambled to
find new flights yesterday it's unclear
if for how many of them will get their
refunds
Jeffrey gazes at Wow's ticket counter at
BWI Airport near Baltimore Jeff they
have they still have a ticket counter
nobody is here and there were so many
confrontations gael between frustrated
passengers and airline employees that
police had to be called to these
counters you know these passengers are
frustrated because unexpectedly what
you've seen is this low-cost airline
it's just shut down
tony was deflate canceled the airline
was cancer chaos continued at airports
on both sides of the Atlantic defeated I
just feel defeated after the low cost
carrier Wow air unexpectedly cut all
flights this couple from Germany spent
hours stranded at BWI yesterday I don't
know if I have to book another flight if
Oporto will help us I don't know I don't
want to stay here for one night Wow flew
about three and a half million people
last year from six North American
airports to 20 cities overseas but The
Associated Press reports the airlines
revenue per passenger was down by about
20 percent in 2017 last December Wow cut
its fleet nearly in half and just this
week two of its planes were repossessed
the airline CEO who once said he hoped
to offer flights for free reportedly
sent a letter to employees Thursday
saying quote I will never forgive myself
for not acting sooner they were not
making money flying people of 5,000
miles for $89 George Howe bika is a
travel expert for the LA Times he says
for people who summer vacation plans on
WoW are now grounded your credit card
company is a good place to start if you
bought your ticket 60 days or fewer you
can go to your credit card company and
get a all your money back through a
chargeback you can also try travel
insurance or other credit cards may
cover things like
hotels that are non-refundable other
airlines are trying to help these
passengers out United Icelandic air
offering what they're calling these
rescue fares that are often hundreds of
dollars less than getting a last-minute
ticket Gail yeah that's a very upsetting
story thank you Jeff the gays so what do
you do good for the other airlines for
offering the the rescue centers I'd be
wagging my finger and saying told you
it's too good to be true $89 and they
call themselves Wow that's what your mom
said if it's too good to be true
normally is